i try to remember how this won't even
cross my path initially
did one of you suggest that i watch and
review this movie
anyhow i was just perusing amazon i came
across i was like oh that sounds
familiar
and i read the premise here's the
premise and this is amazon's description
of the movie to save his declining
business
kris kringle mel gibson also known as
santa claus is forced into a partnership
with the military meanwhile a precarious
12 year old hires a hitman to kill santa
after receiving a lump of coal in his
stocking i don't know what i was
expecting with this movie
but had mel gibson military and a hitman
so i just
expected this really gruff angry mean
santa with
guns to go crazy it's not that it's not
that at all
uh but still we're talking about so
let's get our christmas spirit on
man so fat man refers to santa claus
and i just read the description so i'm
not even gonna do a recap but okay mel
gibson plays santa claus in a world
where
santa's well real and believed to be
real
by everybody i mean of course he's real
in our world kids who shouldn't be
watching my videos but
apparently do but from the get-go this
guy's selling this baseball bat
to walton goggins and it says something
like made in santa's workshop
and they're both like yeah this is worth
about 900 to a thousand bucks because
santa's real and we all kind of know it
but the world is interesting in that
sense because it
kind of breaks down the whole machine
the financial machine that santa is
as santa says in this movie he's the
biggest stimulus that america has
a lot of revenue generated from
christmas but his business is declining
and he's scared of losing it because
the government's like well the money we
give you is based on how many presents
go out and
kids are just shittier now so more coal
is going out
than present so he gets less money and
so he has to make cuts i thought that
was actually
pretty fascinating to be honest with you
i don't know i just
i dug that i dig it when a movie has
something that we all kind of take for
granted like how does santa get
funding how is he able to make all these
toys what's his production
and in the end it has something like
this that explains it but also explains
that
yeah santa can fall on hard times what
can i say i like that also
i really like mel gibson as santa claus
i mean walton goggins
is our hit man and he's exactly what you
need a hitman in this premise to be he's
kind of a weird guy with some quirks but
hitman quirks like he has his little
hamster with him and he carries his
hamster everywhere he's like it's like
someone read a comic book and was like
oh hitmen they need a thing you know he
needs a little pet or something that he
has with him that he really cares for
but he kills human beings and
perfect so he works but mel gibson i
thought he was really good
again i thought it was going to be this
like weird cartoony
santa claus version some hardcore santa
that was just completely unbelievable
and they're just like suspend disbelief
we're here for fun but the movie
actually had a bit of heart
and it's brought by santa and mrs claus
i'll get to her in a second
you really feel for the guy i mean
santa's depressed
because the world is depressing and it's
getting worse so he feels like
he failed the world and he feels like he
failed children everywhere his business
has fallen on hard times
there's a scene where he's addressing
all the elves in the workshop and he's
talking about okay we're gonna help the
military
make weapons just you know to pay the
bills and keep the lights on and
when he's talking his eyes are glazing
up and he's doing that old man you know
like
this isn't what we wanted but we're
gonna get through it also marianne john
baptiste is amazing as mrs claus she is
the rock behind this guy she is the one
keeping him together
she always has the things to say the
speeches to lift him up i mean she
probably doesn't believe
half of it but it's what he has to hear
i thought mel gibson brought the sadness
and sorrow
but she brought the heart i dubbed the
small budget too there are a couple
times where the budget totally shows and
that would usually be one of those
things that takes me out of it it did
kind of take me out of it enough for me
to notice and address but then
enough for me to appreciate the more i
thought about it the more i pondered it
i mean we live in a world where usually
a santa claus movie like this i mean the
workshop would be enormous you'd see
santa's castle but really it's this
humble house with this factory that
doesn't look like
it can produce all these toys going out
there i know i just said
well less toys are going out still you
never see the sleigh
fly he drives a red truck and all of
that's probably because it's like
yeah budget dude we can't make this too
expensive and i appreciated that it's
relying more on imagination and visual
effects the movie could have done better
with its time management it spends a lot
of time building up this little kid
who's clearly a little psychopath whose
sole purpose
in the movie is to get a lump of coal
for christmas because he's a [ __ ]
and then he hires the hitman to go after
santa and now we're kind of on to the
hitman so ironing out that time
management maybe he didn't need a little
kid to hire the hitman the hitman
obviously
hates santa for his own reasons so you
could have just had the hitman who was
once a kid
now go after santa the point is the
movie probably could have been 10
minutes shorter so you do get a pretty
cool confrontation at the end of this
movie so i'm not gonna say oh it's
totally just about santa being in a rut
but that whole
santa mrs claus being in a rut dynamic
with their business it's the thing that
really hooked me even santa's caught up
in the hurricane of 2020 and you just
you feel for it we're all just trying to
make it
to the end again don't know what i was
expecting but i was not expecting to say
fat man is a good time no alcohol
required all right so fat man have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's an obscure
christmas movie that maybe not a lot of
people know about i mean everyone knows
christmas vacation
christmas story we know those what's one
where you're like oh i like this one not
a lot of people do
everyone likes prancer or whatever it
may be but whatever it is whatever you
think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more one magic christmas with giddy
and the angel
i know you're going for that comment
[Music]
section
you